konkreter will react to tape ortheil an
alle englischen zuschauer ich habe
glaube ich gar keine und damit herzlich
willkommen hier heute zum heutigen video
was heute von mir heute heute high
großem hallo hier seht es bereits im
titel eingeblendet meine damen und
herren im heutigen video dreht sich
alles um cape falls sie überhaupt nicht
kennen solltet ihr eine kurze erklärung
hip hop ist ein sammelbegriff für
koreanisch sprachige popmusik und
bezeichnet ein weit gefasstes
musikalisches genre welches sich in den
1990 er jahren in der koreanischen
musikwelt als analogie zum japanischen
jay cop etablierte ich hätte sich besser
auf den punkt bringen können wir haben
unglaublich viele leute in den
kommentaren gesagt luca ria gehen wir
auf cape aber wenn du auf cape reagiert
dann macht es richtig und nicht einfach
so was ist das schöne scheiße bei kate
ist es anscheinend so dass leute die
dahinter stehen und das mega krass
feiern alles andere komplett würden den
grund und boden hätten die dagegen etwas
sagen ich sage hier allerdings nur meine
meinung und ich sage euch ehrlich wie
ich das finde wir fangen an mit dem lied
august die agm wie ich weiß nicht wie
man das ausspricht die tags sagen mir
auch gar nichts das ist halt koreanisch
und wie ich ausspreche koran ist ein
nickerchen
ich find's klasse also das ist das erste
was ich gerade auf play gedrückt habe
irgendwo mitten im song das fand ich
echt gut wir hatten kumpel der sehr
gerne kay pop hört circa zehn lieder
geschickt von natürlich bts die so die
bekanntesten kay top interpreten sind
allerdings auch noch von einigen anderen
künstlern und das ist jetzt das erst
wieder auf das jetzt gerade reagiere und
er hat mir auch genau gesagt okay vom
der stelle bis der stelle
da kriegst du so das beste vom lied mit
und so dass gerade ist echt sehr geil
das ist sonne sehr sehr eigene
musikrichtung irgendwie ich weiß nicht
ob er vorhin wirklich nur panik gesagt
hat hat wirklich don't panic gesagt also
sitzt wohl irgendwie so eine mischung
aus sehr viel koreanisch aber
zwischendurch auch englische begriffe
will ich mir das nur ein oder sind die
musikvideos auch einfach mega krass das
war jetzt gerade beispielsweise nur
englisch das wäre halt so wie werden
deutscher interpret alles auf deutsch
singt aber dann in refrath wieder auf
englisch um noch ein bisschen so die
engländer mit zu holen und ich glaube
das ist ja auch ganz gut gelungen ich
finds auch kraft was in den kommentaren
hier abgeht also te amo mtv also diese
person liegt denen noch nie
hysterisch ding des rap is my wifi dass
das kann ich bestätigen morgens die das
ist wohl wirklich der name von diesem
interpreten
was haben wir noch so ins great want to
be like him
und halt wirklich nur positive
kommentare das hat er mir hier also der
kumpel der mit die ausstatter geschickt
hat auch geschrieben und zwar ist es bei
kate wirklich wohl so dass die mega mega
mega beliebt und mega sympathisch sind
es ist bei kate obwohl so dass die leute
die dort bekannt sind in diesem genre
sich von grund auf alles selbst
erarbeitet haben und wirklich durch not
und elend gegangen sind um dahin zu
kommen wo die jetzt gerade sind deswegen
habe ich auf jeden fall mehr respekt
davor man sieht ja auch schon eine
millionen likes und 9000 discs also das
ist eine mega krasse bewertung einfach
ass de aguiar des tages der first
mixtape album featuring a bis d
das verstehe ich nicht so ganz warum so
oft arg es die ist so heißt der typ a
guest ihren hatten lied gemacht dass es
die heißt million die auch bekannt als
sugar oder arges die ist ein
südkoreanischer rapper songschreiber
tänzer und musikproduzent er hat wohl
mehrere namen was mir auch sehr oft in
die kommentare geschrieben wurde ist
luca jedoch immer noch bts das ist ich
will jetzt nichts falsches sagen aber so
ein bisschen so wohl wie one direction
im cache ob das hier ist die gruppe bts
bzw die bank
die sind sowohl mit die bekanntesten kay
top interpreten die es überhaupt gibt
dts nato day auf fische music video hat
sogar 180 millionen aufrufe das ist das
nächste lied was wir uns jetzt mal
anhören werden
tina damit sind auf tour durch kanada
also was ich direkt sagen muss ich
verstehe kein einziges wort genauso über
august ii beziehungsweise schock oder
das zugleich weiß nicht genau wie ihr
ausgesprochen wird weil ich mich da
wirklich nicht auskenne bei ihm was
vorhin auch so dass ich tatsächlich
überhaupt nichts verstanden habe
deswegen habe ich mich mehr auf sachen
konzentrieren wie beispielsweise wie das
musikvideo aufgebaut und was ich hier
ganz klar sagen muss ist es den mega
großen wert auf choreographie tanzen und
dass alles perfekt ist dass sie darauf
den großen wert legen bieten
allein das gerade in exakt dem gleichen
moment machen nicht nur die bank
handballs die ja quasi die protagonisten
in diesem musikvideo hier sind die
gleiche bewegung sondern auch alle
choreografie tänzer drum rum und das ist
einfach krank
also hier singt er jetzt ich weiß nicht
genau wer ist dann kommen wir noch mehr
leute dazu hier sind dann die meisten
wieder
jetzt haben wir wieder eine choreografie
das kasse ist auch wie heftig mit farben
gespielt wird hier alles so blau und
kalt hier vorne sind sie dann wieder
irgendwo auf einem dach allein wie viele
leute da gerade tanzen das ist heftig
das ist wie eine live-show von paar
tagen ist das neue lied sackboy fontaine
smokers rausgekommen bei den changelog
das besteht das video daraus dass einer
vorne am mikro steht singt einer später
wir und einer macht auf dem schlagzeug
komme da ein bisschen rum und hier das
kommt einem so vor als ob die da
monatelange jahrelange arbeit alleine
die choreografie stecken die sie in den
musik video tanzen
[Musik]
dazu
es ist heftig das einfach
bei mir ist es so dass ich musik sehr
sehr stark danach bewerte was wirklich
in dem vom sage ich mal rüber gebracht
was die message ist also beispielsweise
in jetzt irgendwelchen deutsch pop
liedern um was geht da wirklich nur
darum dass irgendwer die mutter von
irgendwem anders tickt oder der wirklich
eine tiefere message und keine ahnung
äußert kritik am system oder was weiß
ich aber hier verstehe ich wirklich kein
einziges wort was die hier von sich
geben allerdings kann ich sagen dass das
das gesamtkonstrukt ist echt krass geil
ich dachte ich sitze hier und hätte kate
ob in den tod aber ist sehr sehr kalt
als nächstes wollen wir uns hier mal den
steve aoki remix von micro kam auch von
bts weil es die feier ich persönlich
auch deswegen bin ich echt gespannt was
jetzt bei rauskommt
ich finde wieder krass dass die zu
beginn in diesem blauen szenario waren
also hier vorne waren die irgendwo in
diesem blauen szenario dann
katapultierte sich durch das klappt
schon rüber in das hier also sie es es
wird alles so ein bisschen so wie bei
seinem dance battle ich kann das glaube
ich echt schlecht beurteilen weil das so
die ersten lieder sind die ich mir
wirklich an höre ich wollte mir vorhin
die anderen weil ich die life projekt
zurück was in diesem video hier machen
wollte weil mich erinnert das ein
bisschen an step up sorry an alle die
jetzt sagen dass das hier viel krasser
ist natürlich ist das hier viel krasser
aber ich meine das tablet ist es ja auch
so alle tanzen die ganzen
kameraaufnahmen und anbahnen und dann
bleiben was ich wirklich sehr
interessant an kate ob finde ist einfach
kommunizieren irgendwann sepia farben
was ist das gefängnis oder irgendwas
dann sind die hier in irgend einem raum
wo man irgendwas aufnimmt dass hier
wieder komplett rot und übelst geil
choreografie mäßig mir fällt nichts ein
wurde es genauso ist das meine ich das
ist einfach nur perfekt dass sie zu
hause distanzen die gerade in einer
riesigen schwarzen halle von überall
sind scheinwerfer hintergrund ist die vg
irgendwie keine ahnung reingefunden shop
hier oben sind es menschen dadurch
erinnert mich das alles hier so ein
bisschen angst weil ich meinen gästen
auf play
[Musik]
wissen dass ich meine jeder hat so genau
sein party dabei ist genau was er machen
muss jeder hat die perfekte
choreographie alles ist auf einander
perfekt abgestimmt ich schwöre ich höre
ab jetzt wird auch kate hier haben wir
noch ex ok mit overdose es ist so irre
es läuft war sie hier die gleiche
aufnahme die ganze zeit so es werden
hier vorne gezeigt jetzt gehts näher
heran ist passiert kein einziger fehler
in der choreografie er hier vorne wird
gezeigt jetzt wieder jetzt fordert sie
mir in einer anderen perspektive wir
sind immer noch in der gleichen
perspektive ich musste nur schneiden
weil ich nicht mehr einatmen kommt jetzt
wird das team wieder heran gezoomt und
er irgendwie freuen sich jetzt wieder
zurück und jetzt wieder eine andere liga
das ist dass er ist krank es mag wie
kriegt man so was alleine im schnitt
oder ein anderes lied von aixtron zwar
monster
[Musik]
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen dass es
jetzt nicht zum mega krass mein
geschmack aber halt auch wiederholte
heftig gemacht allein mit den farben
alle in die rote angezogen der
hintergrund blau ich muss noch
irgendeine ich springe gegen eine stelle
und wir haben so was wie krass sie das
bitte aus dts feier ist somit das meist
geklickte video von dem also ich habe
mir das jetzt einfach mal kurz an ist
hart ich fand den breakdown gerade
vergleichbar mit rupp an gang am style
wo er auch so bleiben
ob am samstag in lügde und jetzt wisst
ihr was ich meine
auch so breakdown alles ruhig
[Musik]
ja das geil das complete guide alt
verrät droht fand ich ehrlich gesagt
nicht so leicht aber wir spüren hier so
ein bisschen wieder zurück und zwar
jetzt wo diese eine diese neue szene
jetzt eher einsetzen zwar genau ja ich
weiß wirklich nicht über was er da singt
oder keine ahnung was aber so wie das
hier ist wieder aussieht da hängen leds
irgendwie und damit der und brennt was
die leute hier wie sie angezogen sind
es ist etwas ganz ganz eigenes aber
etwas ganz ganz geile star hat mir auch
noch bts dna zugesendet und von bts auch
noch blood sweat and tier ist allerdings
würde ich sagen das ist ja auch noch
sehr sehr viele weitere kay poplieder
gibt ich wollte in diesem video hier
erst mal grob herausfinden was kate ob
wirklich ist also koreanisch sprachiger
pott zwischendurch ein paar englische
begriffe um den mars und beispiele
anschauen wie beispielsweise von orks
die max ots also die bank habe ich mir
jetzt ein paar sachen angeschaut und ich
bin krass begeistert weil bitte nicht
helfen ich hätte gedacht ist es
komplette scheiße handvoll viele leute
über sie geschrieben reagiere auf kurier
pop und da dachte ich erst mal so wir
schreiben auch leute reagieren auf den
fisch aber das interessiert vielleicht
drei leute von meinen keine ahnung
mittlerweile drei millionen abonnenten
aber das kommt wirklich so ein heftiges
ding ist weil ich mein allein wenn man
sich die kommentare anschaut sind die
meisten auf englisch die sind
international bekannt obwohl die nicht
mehr primär englisch singen ich bin auch
ein mensch der eigentlich nur
elektronische musik hört also auch sehr
sehr gerne trap und das ist einfach so
ein perfekter schwung zwischen ehrman
aber irgendwie auch elektronisch aber
auch mit einem treppe hintergedanken ich
könnte das jetzt noch jahrelang hier
zusammenfassen wie ich klopfte er hat
mir auch geschrieben wirklich dass die
leute die das machen wohl die
sympathischen menschen der welt sind
weil sie auch die ganze zeit an sich
selbst arbeiten auch in interviews wohl
unglaublich respektvoll miteinander und
mit mitmenschen umgehen das schätze ich
sehr an solchen künstlern und ich muss
wirklich sagen ich bin sehr sehr
überzeugt davon schreibt mir gerne mal
eure meinung zu pop und indie kommentare
und was eure lieblingsband ist und auf
was ich eventuell das nächste mal
reagieren soll